yesterday we did the defensive players
with whom we would start a franchise
uh my picks were better than chris's
picks we've had
all over social media so you can react
no correct absolutely correct amundo you
can check them out everywhere on social
media all right let's do it today for
the offensive side of the ball
quarterbacks excluded
offensive players with whom we'd start a
franchise chris you've got a trivia
question for me yeah i do and i don't
think your picks were better than me
yesterday i almost want to ask you to
put up a poll right now i think i would
win that poll here we go two rookies
have won nfl
uh mvp two rookies have won nfl mvp
can you name
one of them
gale sayers oh
so close it was a running back but
jim brown and earl
campbell yeah the tyler rose they used
to call earl campbell
i i object 55 years later on gail
sayer's behalf he should have been the
mvp in 1965 do you we know who the mvp
was in 1965 uh um i have not gail sayers
no i'm not do you know
it's like bart starr or somebody like
that i don't know here's what will
happen yeah i'll say that i will look it
up in a break and we'll let everyone
know before the end of the show and then
i'll forget to do it so we'll we'll look
it up during a break
jim brown in 65 too okay we don't have
to worry he dominated that reward for a
while all right go ahead take a pic
here we go this is it's this is good i'm
going to go with george kittle as my
first pick right now to start a
franchise that's going to be my guy was
that going to be your first pick i was
like kind of going to he was on my list
yeah i was going to listen
last year i was going to lay in the
weeds here but i was like i don't know
florian might take him first so i am
going to take george kittle first off
special i mean special player you know
that it's one of the best blocking tight
ends in football which is remarkable
because he has to eat like panda express
four times a day to be 248 pounds and
then we know what he can do in the past
game you know this is the best tight end
in the game and to me you know with a
guy like kittle to start your franchise
you're getting somebody that can affect
both areas of your offense if you were
starting a franchise with so he'll help
your run game and of course he'll help
your pass game and he'll help everything
else too bring energy to the field every
day because he's a psycho in a good way
just as you're seeing in this clip and
he's that kind of guy you want to start
your franchise with
in a season without fans in the stands i
want him on the field right he's going
to get everyone going no matter what
he's got that brian dawkins element to
him where he's going to get you fired up
before the game so he was on my list i
don't know that i would have taken him
first probably second but it's moot now
because you have taken him first overall
i'm going christian mccaffrey how can
you not go christian mccaffrey christian
because george kelly does it all well
that's right
and today
my draft is going to be better than your
draft christian mccaffrey the first
thousand yard rusher thousand yard
receiver uh since marshall faulk roger
craig the only other one to do it he's
in his prime right now and he's happy
with his contract and he's in position
to come out and make a huge difference
the problem is he's on a team that is
going to have a hard time being
competitive this year but if i'm
starting a franchise running back hey i
i kill two birds with one stone if i get
christian mccaffrey because he's going
to be catching passes and he's going to
be running the ball and he's going to be
helping me win games yeah all right it's
hard to really argue with that i mean
here this is where i'm not sure if i
want to go lineman here or if i want to
go like wide receiver and do something
like that that's where i'm a little
stuck
i'm i'm gonna go lineman i'm gonna give
some love to to the big guys all right
i'm gonna go with the guy that i think's
the best left tackle in the game right
now and that's ronnie stanley uh for for
the baltimore ravens you know you can
never go wrong with that again hey we
know df you want to protect a
quarterback you want to give you know
running backs holes anything like that
uh we don't talk about lyman enough uh
as far as their their what they do to a
team and a game and those battles that
are won up front and that's why
baltimore is amazing because they got a
lot of good offensive linemen who can
dominate but ronnie stanley to me a guy
that's great in the run game and it
doesn't matter who you got as a pass
rusher he can handle him off the edge so
he'd be a guy i'd look at you know allah
the jacksonville jaguars taking a tony
biselli if i had to start one i'd go
with stanley right now
yeah here's why i don't have any lyman
on my list because you're a hater of big
people that's why no no
other than you no
they're uh
you can have one great offensive lineman
and what's that going to do for you you
you you need to have all good to great
offensive linemen or that one great
offensive lineman doesn't mean anything
thank you captain obviously we know that
yeah but i'm going to start with one i'm
going to start with a great one before i
get there
i'm starting a franchise with a guy
whose greatness is going to stand out
regardless of whether or not we are able
to round out the roster around him i
can't believe you've left tyree kill on
the board this long he's your number one
receiver and look because of the speed
the stop and the start the extra
attention he commands he is
today's randy moss now look he doesn't
have the same size he i i think that
moss was better than tyree kill but
tyree kill's got the explosion he he's
the the constant threat every team wants
that threat he is that threat that keeps
you
constantly watching him and accounting
for him and opening up the rest of the
offense so uh you know i don't need to
have another great receiver if i have
tyree kill if i have ronnie stanley i
still need to have another great lineman
or my quarterback's going gonna be dead
so give me tyree kill this is shaping up
to be a very good day yeah good good
good pick i mean yes uh he is the guy
who i was thinking about you know when i
was talking about do i go to a receiver
offensive line but you're right you know
and again you know i i've seen people
you know on on social media and things
like that like oh you know he's not a
good or a route runner as some of the
other guys on on the on my top ten list
or whatever who gives a damn what is rot
running look at what this route running
is here run straight and run by
everybody oh great give him the ball and
let him run straight who the hell cares
about his route running he's got a skill
like you're saying that is great that
overcomes some of the deficiencies he
might have as a player i mean come on
he's a difference maker he's not even a
wide receiver he's a weapon so i'm with
you i didn't think you'd do it i didn't
think you'd take them that's why i left
them there um all right there's plenty
of great route runners that run a 4-8
yeah right right exactly all right i'm
going to go with michael thomas then my
next guy i mean he's in the prime of his
career you know and i'm you know for a
lot of the same reasons you know michael
thomas he's dependable he's tough he's
going to bring attitude to your team you
know talk about it it catches everything
that's in his vicinity and you know
he's a guy that you can formulate an
offense around like we're seeing so yeah
if i'm starting an organization and you
know i'm the coach or whatever i know i
got enough good plays in my playbook
that i can get him the ball and he's the
guy that you can depend on to get open
against anybody let alone
the thing that's so impressive is when
he's covered he still catches the ball
so much it's it's truly phenomenal you
know he's one of the best best in as we
see in this highlight right there one of
the best in traffic wide receivers i've
ever seen really he's totally fearless
so i'll go with michael thomas
yeah look i i i thomas how does thomas
number three on your receiver list
behind julio julio's too old i can't
start him as a i don't want to start a
franchise with him i'm a little worried
about julio and his age where michael
thomas is stopping right yesterday when
you took aaron donald right out of the
gates but another reason why i won
yesterday you did not win yesterday
saquon barkley how have you overlooked
saquon barkley my goodness i mean we we
have the injury last year that he
suffered against the buccaneers fairly
early in the season and then returned
from too quickly and it hampered him all
year long he didn't have the kind of
production that he had as a rookie we've
kind of taken because why injury
happened does he hurt a little bit too
oh but my point but my point is
when a guy's coming back and he's less
than 100 percent but he's dedicated to
the game and his numbers aren't as great
as they otherwise would have been we
kind of forget about him i think saquon
barkley is a guy you definitely build
around he and if you're going to make
him the second overall pick in the draft
he's got to be adrian peterson he's got
to be the guy that your offense runs
through and the rookie year it took them
a while to figure out that they needed
to make him the focal point of the
offense but again it's just like with
tyreek hill and with christian mccaffrey
if i'm starting my franchise with those
guys i don't need to have as great of a
of a group of players around them if i'm
starting with those guys yeah i i hear
you now i mean you might have to you
know look for replacements for those
running backs three years from now i get
you you know because if i drafted the
running vacs you'd be like oh they're
growing on trees why would you draft a
running back i know that's what you'd
say to me so i just wanted to say that i
like my team i spread the wealth a
little too you know you got your your
you know run two running backs i i want
to give the big guys some love
yeah well i could have taken two
receivers i was thinking about devante
adams oh you're funny you're funny
a real funny guy
take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports